this morning flags are flying half staff
for general colin powell the former
secretary of state and chairman of joint
chiefs of staff died yesterday he was
84. in a tribute president biden said
powell believed in the promise of
america because he lived it cbs news
chief political analyst john dickerson
looks at powell's path to success in one
moment that he admitted to falling short
as a teen colin powell took what we
would now call a selfie
his poise suggests a successful future
was inevitable four star general
national security advisor and the first
african-american chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff and the first black
secretary of state
but powell would insist success was not
inevitable it depended on a country that
would welcome his immigrant parents and
a city that would offer free college to
a middling student aimless he fell in
love with another american avenue of
opportunity the military the army took
in a young black kid from rotc in the
south bronx and brought him to this
point powell's rise in the military was
not hastened by west point or the naval
academy i stand here today as a direct
descendant
of those buffalo soldiers and of the
tuskegee airmen and all the black men
and women who have served the nation in
uniform i didn't just show up
i climbed on the backs of those who
never had the kind of opportunity that i
had
powell served in vietnam south korea and
germany and he served in uniform in the
reagan bush and clinton administrations
in 2000 he declared a political party my
fellow republicans it's a wonderful
evening here tonight
he joined george w bush's administration
and a career defined by fighting the
russians during the cold war would end
being defined by the war on terrorism
and his turn on the global stage at the
united nations
a blot the failure will always be
attached to me in my un presentation
during the successful first gulf war
powell had built credibility our
strategy to go after this army is very
very simple first we're going to cut it
off and then we're going to kill it he
put that credibility on the line making
the case that iraq's leader had weapons
of mass destruction but he was wrong
iraq had no massive cache of weapons the
intelligence on which powell had relied
fell apart a career spent arguing that
the lessons of america's failure in
vietnam demanded care and restraint
became forever linked to a costly hasty
mistake in private life powell continued
to sound the alarm in 2008 he spoke out
against his party's overt appeal to
racism in its attacks on barack obama i
have heard senior members of my own
party
drop this suggestion he's a muslim and
he might be associated with terrorists
this is not the way we should be doing
it in america but powell's faith in
america never waned because he was
always ready to see its promise in the
daily acts of its citizens in 2019 while
fixing a flat tire a fellow veteran and
amputee stopped to help him pal wrote to
the good samaritan on facebook
thanks anthony you touched my soul and
reminded me about what this country is
all about and why it's so great in
return all anthony asked for his payment
for his good deed was what an immigrant
son could never know would become a
prize
a selfie with colin powell
john dickerson is with us right now john
good morning
some would describe his legacy as
complex i would say highly decorated
highly respected how will he be
remembered both can be true and it's
important you know colin powell would
say you have to remember both when you
read his books and you look at his
lessons one of the big ones is learn
from your mistakes but the arc of his
life is uh the american story somebody
who was given these opportunities and
who sees them and by the way he was
given these opportunities not because he
was a superstar he was not a good
athlete he was not a good student but
the american system had a place for him
and then he could take advantage of it
and so is both the american story and
how to rise in that uh and then also the
complexities of iraq let's talk about
colin powell the man
just the way you ended that piece john
just sort of i was so filled last night
looking at all the accolades about him
from both sides of the aisle and people
were talking about the type of man that
he was and his style of leadership but
let's talk about colin powell the man
what can you tell us about him well
there are a lot of ways to lead one is
you give great speeches one is you you
go and do great things the other is what
you do day to day when you interact with
other people and he was you know this he
was this he had an
a a laugh that was concussive it like
filled up a room like an explosion quick
laugh um and was good to people the
little people there are lots of people
telling stories about being around colin
powell being nervous
but him treating them like they were you
know the most important person in the
room that model secretary canalisa rice
writes about it that model as a person
is also a kind of leadership and it was
decent it meant kindness and it meant
integrity when challenged the
appreciations rolled in from every
living president save for one that would
be donald trump and it makes me wonder
whether the direction of our politics
means we're moving away from a colin
powell style of leadership does it still
exist
it exists in boardrooms it exists in
some politicians in washington it exists
anybody anywhere people have to lead
other human beings because his lessons
for leadership are uh the ones that that
people keep coming back to and obviously
exists in the sports world we um you
know there is a very popular
person in the republican party who
chooses to lead in a very different way
um but that is almost um
it almost proves the point about the
powell school of leadership um and one
thing we have to wrestle with and with
his legacy and again he would have been
very clear on this is
his argument for the invasion of iraq
was based on what they thought was true
at the time different than what we talk
about with lies now but it's really
important to go back and study how you
can get it wrong and have consequences
that are that great and you also own
that too own it yeah yeah that's
self-accountability and own it but the
crucial thing is not own it to move on
and get to the next thing yeah but own
it and understand it and why that
mistake was made because he was obsessed
with vietnam and not repeating the
mistakes of vietnam right and yet that's
partially what people say happened with
iraq john dickerson thank you very much
glad to see you here at the table yes
great to be here